[Music]  when i think of the justice league  i think of wonder woman  superman  green lantern you don't want to mess  with that one but you  barry  you're just the team mascot aren't you  mate the loser of the league folks the  fastest man alive it's  the [ __ ]  flash is alive and he's playing for team  brainiac  i gave you orders  kill the flash i'll kill you myself  [Music]  nothing can stop me  really  why don't you just mail me the bullet  i'm the eye in the sky taking point for  you shark  pulverized  who else needs to bash it  [Music]  oh yeah  oh  [Music]  no escape from my wrath  you want to see what a real hero can do  come on  really thought flasher had  [Music]